still emotional Sheila flew here to
Minnesota to find answers on how prince
died she spent last night inside the
artist ten million dollar Paisley Park
compound where he was found unresponsive
rooms include this massive recording
studio this eclectic lounge area with
large projectors and screens and this
so-called relaxation room which
showcases the singers love of purple
some monument it's a museum it's been a
lot of fun in that building I have heard
that there is an underground vault there
that Prince holds a lot of his
recordings there's a place down here
that if tornados happen that's where
you're gonna go the bunker yes I got you
there have been reports that maybe there
was a problem with painkillers was he
having trouble with his hip still I mean
you think about all the years that he
was jumping off those risers I mean they
were they were not loathed you had those
heels on it would have messed up his
knees and then him doing the splits you
know he was in pain all the time going
inside princes private world the 57 year
old reportedly didn't like the internet
or cell phones he didn't trust iTunes or
sites like YouTube and as for religion
he converted from being a seventh-day
Adventist to Jehovah's Witness in 2001
he was this different weird androgynous
sexy person that we were weirdly and
wildly attracted to and didn't
understand why he's just like how can
you be prettier than me I don't
understand well you make a better than